quelques heures après l'accident les
habitants de charolles sont sous le choc
mais pour autant pas surpris ici les
dangers de la rcea sont connus et
redouté une scène ne surprend pas
vraiment et quand on va sur l'autre côté
sur paray-le-monial je crois c'est pire
encore puisqu'elle des dos d'âne énorme
la pâte visibilité on arrive très
brusquement sur un camion et ça peut
faire beaucoup de dégâts
j'ai perdu nos marraines sur l'incident
de la route sur cette route il ya
quelques années voilà lé meurtrière on
l'a toujours su c'était la 79 avant n79
maintenant l'air ce soit et quoi faire
pour arranger tout ça je ne sais pas
vraiment même si les causes de
l'accident d'autocar de ce matin sont
certainement lié aux conditions
climatiques et notamment au verglas
le maire de charolles rappelle l'urgence
du réaménagement de cette route à fort
trafic
on peut penser effectivement que c'est
bien les conditions climatiques qui ont
engendré cet accident mais je pense que
si nous avions eu deux fois deux voies
le bus aurait peut-être traverser le
terre-plein central mais il y aurait eu
une route à côté quoi alors bien sûr
tout sûr que des hypothèses mais tout
cas
ce que je peux vous dire que sur ceux
encore ce drame qui s'est déroulé chez
nous c'est plus dans quelques semaines
les travaux en deux fois deux voies vont
commencer sur le tronçon charolles paray
le monial
mais la route jusqu'à mâcon risque
d'être longue puisque aucun travaux
n'est prévue dans l'immédiat